my inspiration comes from nature through  the places that I've traveled and  pushing myself as far as I can  [Music]  this is insane  I love discovering the regionality of  Cuisine and just how different it can be  wherever you are  one of the best ways I think to  experience geology is through flavors  I've always wanted to go out and forage  with a professional  never seen anything like this before  I feel like a kid in a candy store right  now  [Music]  rocks being eroded ultimately creating  soils I thought this be a good place for  breakfast  thank you so much it's the coolest thing  I've ever done it all comes together  when you travel to a new place  experience the colors and the flavors of  what's around you it's incredible it's  incredible  [Music]  stream on Hulu October 25th